cada día aumenta en alemania la presión
para que las autoridades tanto a nivel
federal como regional relajen algunas de
las restricciones estrictas que han
estado vigentes en el país desde el
pasado mes de diciembre y que han
llevado la disminución considerable en
el número de infecciones y de muertes
por coronavirus si se compara la
situación con el final del año pasado y
de ahí que se espera que en la reunión
que sostendrán este miércoles la
canciller angela merkel y los 16 líderes
regionales se anuncien relajaciones
puntuales relajaciones que han sido
descritas como pequeñas y prudentes como
la reapertura de ciertos
establecimientos comerciales como las
librerías o la posibilidad de que más
personas puedan reunirse de manera
privada se espera en este punto que
hasta dos unidades familiares y un
máximo de cinco adultos puedan empezar a
reunirse tras el anuncio de este
miércoles al mismo tiempo sin embargo se
espera que la mayoría de las
restricciones que están vigentes se
extiendan hasta finales de mes hasta el
28 de marzo esta doble estrategia por un
lado anunciar ciertas áreas donde habrá
relajaciones y por el otro lado extender
ciertas restricciones
ya que si bien los números de
infecciones han caído en alemania está
aumentando la preocupación por las
variantes de coronavirus en particular
por la presencia de la variante
británica del coronavirus aquí en
alemania